It is clearly now the will of the parliamentary Conservative Party...
...that there should be a new leader of that party...
...and therefore, a new prime minister.
Boris Johnson is stepping down as the UK's prime minister,...
...unable to overcome a string of scandals around unlawful parties...
...during the pandemic and broader questions about his integrity.
In less than three years, he's gone from this to this.
Apologies to everybody for the misjudgments that I've made,...
...that we may have made.
Johnson enjoyed a steady rise from journalist to London mayor to prime minister...
...despite gaffes that sometimes led to accusations of racism, sexism...
...and spreading misinformation.
I'm sorry for the offense that I have caused,...
...but I will continue to speak as directly as I can.
Johnson was once considered the golden boy of the Conservative Party.
So how did he climb so high?
And why did his premiership fall apart?
To answer that question,...
...we need to understand what sort of politician Boris Johnson is,...
...which means going right back to the start.
What are you not ashamed of there, Boris?
Whatever there is not to be ashamed of.